thank you
[Music]
some of you guys know smack that's um my
girlfriend of Mac like seven years now
she got radio videos uh yeah so my
girlfriend she's a commercial actress
and also does social media she's a
Creator on it's funny because I'd be
seeing her on commercials like yeah just
from time to time I remember starting to
seeing a story yeah yeah so she's she's
from Australia originally and uh she
what she always used to tell me about
this uh she was part of this
um theater group in Brisbane and the uh
I think it's like the main theater group
over there that they'll just do like big
Productions of different plays and
musicals How to Train Your Dragon well
not that that's Pixar uh she she booked
that and that's what got her here but
the one there they would just do local
like Australia shows and like you know
things like uh like Greece or you know
things like that it'll just be that's
who does it out there and uh she used to
tell me about him and she was like yeah
um so when I was part of this group uh
she had a ton of like you know when you
grow up around theater people you tend
to have a lot of like closeted gay
friends and then uh she she remembers
like her and these are like her friends
that she loves like they're a bunch of
guys that were kind of afraid to come
out because I think that theater group
had some kind of connection with the
church so there was a lot of pressure to
not you know not come out and um that
pressure also bled into uh some of the
people that were the leaders so there
was the main director guy who was
um he was married with kids and
everything and she would always tell me
about like yeah but that dude was like
he was doing some stuff like uh like
like he had boyfriends on the side yeah
and they weren't always of age oh yikes
and she would always tell me these crazy
stories and I was I would Mentor yeah
and I would be like dude like that's
like you know that's that's not good
like I mean she knows it's not good but
it's also super not common like for
things like that to go un uh solved like
that it's just a thing in her memory and
um and then
she's got her own issues as well with
this thing that'll probably come out
later but uh a lot of her friends were
victims of this guy
yeah of this um the lead director who
was like married with kids and and he
was molesting the boys yeah and so she
had
um
she basically had like made this post on
her socials that were kind of talking
about it basically like her memory of it
and like a bunch of her friends were
like yeah I remember that and all these
people were relating that they also
um remembered these things happening
this theater group had only gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger so uh same
director and all that same director wow
over here now like very far removed from
that whole thing like she has friends
that are still back there doing things
but as far as in this company she
doesn't really I don't think she has any
like closer connections with him but
then yesterday she's like
holy [ __ ] like you'll never believe what
happened she shows me an article
and it literally says um
detectives from Hendra criminal
investigation branch and child abuse
sexual crime group have charged a 41
year old man with 69 offenses oh my God
why 69 with that's an unfortunate number
you know I mean they could have done
like one more or one less about 60. but
God damn they just want to be accurate
though facts for facts buddy yeah facts
are facts shine offenses against
um uptick eight boys whoa that's crazy
between 12 and 29 between 2001 and 2021.
whoa and she remembers
some of those boys on the list right
they're still her friends today yes holy
[ __ ] they're all they're all finally
getting this Justice or at least closer
to it wow for this thing that she grew
up
and also like that that had huge effects
on her like that was you know that that
was her first experience or first like
interaction with
um anything of sexual connotation with
this exact Scandal and she you know had
a hard time
sort of normalizing outside of that like
we would talk and stuff about like hey
like you know that could have really
[ __ ] up your perspective on like
What's
um normal yeah or like it could have
made a fear the way that she found out
was that her friend was confining into
her saying like I've been like assaulted
by our director and then she's just like
oh my God and that's the first time she
heard it like or was it a rumor or do
you know how it went down they were like
as she was growing up like this was in
her early teens she would just see these
things kind of happening what do you
mean like they're making out and [ __ ] in
front of her yeah they were just there
would just be little things going on
here and there and then little stories
like it's like your friend group imagine
like when you're part of your church or
something and then like all the members
of the church and you spend all your
time together that's your main thing and
uh she would just see certain things and
behaviors that are coming way too soon
before you know what's okay and what's
not yeah and uh and she was just she her
whole like sentiment about her and her
friends is they were all just super
innocent like all they wanted to do was
dance and perform and just be theater
kids and in a lot of like theater cases
that is the situation where they're just
they just want to be part of it and
perform and then you know somebody takes
advantage and begins grooming and then
you can't even tell that you're in
trouble yeah like you don't even know
because all you care about is the
satisfaction of other people approving
of you and you know like they build this
like weird symbiotic relationship of
like no I don't want to disappoint you
and then it becomes this thing like
what's happened here and the crazy thing
is I didn't think this would ever happen
because she's always been like yeah you
know they
uh this all took place but
even at the time everyone was afraid to
speak up yeah and everybody was afraid
nothing would get done if they did they
would just feel ashamed and that news
would be out and they would you know
feel disgusted with them to see the
director as like of someone oh he
probably does have immense amount of
power in that industry and yeah and
leverage you know and that's the crazy
thing and I would always ask her from my
outside perspective I'm like how much of
a [ __ ] denialist is are these people
in when uh she was she would tell me
that it's so flat out in front of
everybody like he eventually left his
family or his wife
um and then just came out as gay and had
a partner and so like okay that's a step
in the direction of what you know
because she always knew like oh this
guy's like totally closet gay you know
but then um he contained this man
continued to uh be in charge of this
theater group and they continued to
operate and only grew bigger
and um so he just molested more boys
yeah and there's more and the crazy
thing is is there's more than just him
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you mean there's other
leaders here that are molesting kids
according to according to smack he's not
the only one and uh yeah and there is
another guy that that's still working
there there's another well I don't think
that the whole thing's kind of at a halt
right now because it's everything's kind
of stopped for this investigation but
there is one other person who's like a
35 year old guy that's that's being
charged with five counts and he's
someone that she doesn't know like he
came later so it's almost like this
thing that's been going on for decades I
mean this theater company is as old as
1989 or something like that and uh maybe
anything that involves kids it just
attracts pedals and [ __ ] like like they
want to work
where they can get
[ __ ] like that
because that shit's weird because you
see it in every like [ __ ] industry
like that right yeah you hear about it
all the time I mean there's def the
risks are higher for sure I think in in
theater or in um gymnastics like yeah
gymnastics terrible risks there yeah
huge risks and anything was it the
Olympic doctor [ __ ] Larry Nasser
touching like hundreds of girls and [ __ ]
yeah absolutely I feel like I think it's
a respect empowered and then they don't
write them out to like I'm sure with the
theater when you respect somebody so bad
you're like oh maybe yeah yeah I think
that's a that that really when it comes
down to her describing it to me it's a
lot of uh you know sometimes in people's
heads the person that's the Molester is
not always the creep sometimes it's the
most charismatic person in the room
sometimes it's the coolest guy yeah
sometimes it's the most like uplifting
like person you want to be around and
then when no one else is around and
you're one to one damn you get a
different perspective of who they are
and you also don't want to uh ruin the
relationship and it's a lot of pressure
on young people to like especially in a
in a situation where uh
their favoritism of you it could be
celebrated like people go oh he loves
you oh you're so lucky like the director
loves you like you know it's a it's a
point of Pride yeah it it's a bad recipe
basically if you have one wrong
ingredient but that's the thing though
right like guys like that
or just people like that in general they
are predators they know how to work that
game they know how to like manipulate
people and that's what they are at the
highest level right they are
manipulators they know how to be in
front of people and be charismatic they
know how to do all the right things all
the right notes but then behind closed
doors they know how to play those heart
strings on on the people that they're
pressurable exactly yeah in their heads
they might be like we're in love
you know like it's a secret love affair
that you guys don't ever understand I'm
keeping the secret like they're
manipulated they don't [ __ ] know
until later they get older and they're
like hold the phone dude that [ __ ] was
like wrong you know who was even saying
that like once she posted this article
on her social and her friends who all
like kind of already know this [ __ ] that
they're still to this day people that
were involved in this are like who do
you think they're talking about oh my
God and there's such [ __ ] Advanced
denial that it's like they are still
willing to say I wonder who it is even
though they were a part of it exactly
sometimes denial is convenient you mean
the victims are denying it or no just
like other people that were that were in
the like uh collaterally involved even
from a like a like a victim perspective
like imagine there's there's like maybe
trying to seek justice but like
sometimes at what cost if you feel like
comfortable in your skin like at a later
point in your life to like bring it up
or to make something public you know
what I mean or to like to even just dive
back into that it's like look I spent
like half of my life trying to get out
of it like now it's now it's being
uncovered and there's Justice to be
sought but at what cost to to even
confront it means that everybody in my
ecosystem today has to be aware and
understand and you relive it in a more
public way yeah you know what I'm saying
that's judgment from other people yeah
so it can be probably like
pretty pretty just harsh on the mind is
all you know oh yeah yeah it could be
mindful that's what that's what smacks
thing is is like uh it's pretty crazy to
know that like so in our early years of
of us being together that's always been
a thing that I understood was like a
personal trauma first I'm like the time
that she had went through this and like
the hardship that it must have taken for
her to figure out what was actually
correct
um and and then years later
after thinking oh that's just the past
like hey if you know I I always told her
too I'm like hey like if you if you're
healed from that we don't gotta [ __ ]
revisit it or like we don't have to talk
about it like it's fine like that's if
you're good and life is good then I'm
not gonna be like go back there and find
them and prosecute like yeah whatever
dude but she's like she's like yeah I
think it's good like we're you know and
then this happened it's like and you
know what's crazy is the number is way
the [ __ ] higher than she even thought so
that means that like
and now in her mind
is she wants the rest of them going down
too because if you don't that number
will keep going yeah because they're
still there because they're still there
and some of them have moved on to other
companies and other areas where there's
a whole slew of new kids that don't know
[ __ ] the Catholic Church
yep yeah that that's different that's
like you know uh unfortunately a call to
social responsibility when you like have
some sort of knowledge or an
understanding that could potentially
prevent like harm to like other people
you know innocent people too I I um
don't want to self-incriminate myself
but when I was a little bit
um uh more on the dangerous side of
before JK and all this stuff when me and
my friends
would hear stories about things like
this
um we didn't go to the authorities
we allegedly we allegedly we we met like
just for imagination hypothetical fun
times yeah we uh JK Funtime stories we
returned various favors
and that was a really satisfying point
in my life that I was like this is the
type of things that I like to do
um and like I felt like Batman a little
bit but then like we all knew and they
knew and I don't know if that stopped
though but at least I know that my
friends who got assaulted got their uh
retribution Revenge yeah and one of our
character
um techniques was to
um burn eyebrows so like you knew that
people walking around with burnt
eyebrows were rapists wow that's so
after we were this is just imaginary
comic book like like if it happened you
know what I mean like I didn't do
anything myself if if like you know
going back to the scenario like if what
would be the weapon of choice to to burn
off eyebrows would it be like lighters
oh yeah just like Batman at the end
that's again at the end you know like
and then when you walk when you saw the
guy at school or or just walking around
hypothetically with burnt eyebrows
everyone in the community kind of knew
that
um they did something wrong to women yep
especially women in our Circle right
yeah yeah Japanese and that's the sad
thing is sometimes that's all some
people have because they it's out of the
question for some people to go to
Authority sometimes especially when
you're young you don't know how to yeah
you don't really know what to do yeah
exactly so that's what's [ __ ] up and I
feel like that helpless weird feeling
you know like you you don't have any
that's why it's so important to have
violent Brothers sometimes oh my God I I
would wish there was a Japanese Batman
at my school
seriously that would be so nice
that's a good because like if the
teacher asks what's your One Wish Jason
Japanese Batman please
yeah I mean again like not everybody has
a Japanese Batman or a Australian
Superman do they name the guy in the
article in the article uh
they do not name him uh not in this
article because they're still
investigating
um I think that name will be coming real
soon
um and maybe schmack will come and like
tell us more about it at some point but
it's it's a huge I think like what a
milestone in your own life to have a
personal like demonized era finally come
to life and in this way like it was last
night that she showed me this how old
was she when she left this company when
she left well when she left uh she was
18. got it damn yeah I might take a
visit to Australia and you might see
some burnt eyebrows
it's Japanese Batman